judah's Foster Family says his death
should have never happened they say DCS
failed him they just simply didn't do
their job they didn't do what they were
supposed to but didn't follow up Ed they
followed up they would have seen the red
flags as candles burned tributes were
paid to four-year-old Judah Morgan
loved ones held Justice for Judah signs
as community members stood together in
support it was sweet
as loving caring very caring Judah was
placed with his cousin Jenna holett at
four months old following abuse
allegations within his home Judah was
born with a large amount of THC in his
system from my understanding and like I
said I wanted him with family what
I believe that it means that the mother
was abusing drugs while he was inside
THC specifically we no yeah specifically
I'm not unaware of this but maybe you
could film a large amount right I'm
going to wear this you can fill me in
if you are pregnant what are the effects
of wheat on a child inside the womb is
it like well it's growing even even in a
teenager it's not good because it can
stand your growth it can modify your
brain and stuff like that so that's not
good that's why it's not give it to kids
yeah that's why it's not good right and
that's why it's very comfortable in some
instances to give it to to kids but also
uh it can help kids with seizure and
stuff like that so sometimes it depends
on what that's in a medical sense
exactly
yeah but if you have a large amount of
and the bird like a kid has nothing it
can affect it you know I mean it's all
right Judah was with her for four years
but was reunited with his birth parents
Mary Yoder and Alan Morgan in April
they're both charged in his death after
Judah was found with blunt force trauma
Sunday what made this blunt force trauma
that means they smashed him until he
passed
that's what that means either they threw
him or smashed him but that's what that
means let's um give him back to his
parents
long story short they dropped the ball I
mean they told me on super two separate
occasions the LaPorte County um
regional manager had told me that they
were to file uh
um termination of parental rights on two
different occasions and for some unknown
reason they failed to do so and all he
could do is apologize and he said they
just had to start the case over
according to the police report judah's
mother called 9-1-1 stating judah's
father lost his temper and hurt him
investigators found Judah inside a
bedroom naked covered in a blanket with
bruises all over his body and on his
face and head his mother told
investigators Judah was sent to the
basement around three times a week for
punishment for not being potty trained
like his other three siblings in the
house the lights were purposely shut off
as a quote scare tactic and food was
withheld from him he was potty trained
when he was two the report also shows
judah's mother said Judah was forced to
stay in the basement naked with only a
fuzzy blanket for days before being
allowed back upstairs and that his
father would duct tape his hands and
feet and physically abuse him holit
describes judah's parents as monsters
for what they did that's the hardest
part it's hard for him to be gone but
the details are eating at me the police
report States judah's mother would tell
his father things like that's enough but
didn't stop the abuse conditions inside
were described as having a strong
pungent odor of urine and rotting food
with clothing garbage and animal fecal
matter all over the house the
refrigerator had a court attached
preventing anyone from opening it
according to the documents this is an
addict's home yes
this is an addict yes a hundred percent
you have people with all kinds of
traumas using all kinds of substances
with kids who are already like
negatively impacted by their this is a
recipe for disaster
so what happened is that your the
services release the child into the
family without looking at the you know
so originally the kid was with the
family very young yeah they found signs
of yeah bad behavior so they took it but
we put them in someone else and then
they returned the child I understood
that right when they returned the child
they didn't check
you gotta check no you don't apparently
no you don't apparently so
um
I like I like the mother just being like
the father was the one who did it
I I like I ain't got I ain't got much I
ain't got much to say about this to be
honest with you there's not much to say
about this uh uh give him the chair and
stop the chair when they're about to die
and repeat
until they finish suffering and they die
from that
that would be my take and I know it's
pretty hard to do and human but I don't
really care that's what they deserve
they deserve to suffer as much as that
kid suffer that's well that's my take
personally I don't think the chair I
mean that's the whole argument what's
better the chair or you know living the
long lives in prison with all that
that's a that's that's that that is that
is that is an image for suffering a long
ass time that's one of the [__]
to suffer that's for me no really I
don't really have sympathy for that you
can't have the child you'd be giving
back to you and then that happened yeah
you're an addict hollett says she warned
DCS multiple times that he was In Harm's
Way but nothing was done she repeatedly
told me you know they're not listening I
keep going to them I'm telling them
what's happening they're not listening I
don't know what to do the family says
the system horrifically mishandled their
case you need to stop
this from happening ever again it should
have never happened with Judah he was
safe
and and loved and
taking care of with us the family is
hoping to establish a new law in judah's
name in the meantime they encourage the
community to email local legislators and
Senators with their concerns about the
foster care system like I said I think
it's a systemic issue that's my
suspicion yeah because here's the thing
there's there's always differences
there's sometimes there's [__] bags who
work at a certain place and do things
incorrectly and other times there's just
laws in place or bylaws a place where
they can't do anything their hands are
cut and if they were they would be
acting illegally then they would be
jailed for intervening so this is a
tough situation but it's like that
systems like that are in place and a lot
of people aren't aware that like the
foster care system is can be terrible
like the places that you get put into
can be terrible but sometimes your
original living situation is even worse
so there's no easy easy solutions to
this it does it's a weird thing to say
it does warm my heart to see that this
woman cared so deeply that she's going
this far and she's trying to change laws
to do everything to honor that boy I
think if everyone is born into a family
with half as much interest and care for
the child as this woman had I think a
lot of us would be end up in much better
places it's not weird
it's not weird it's I understand that it
warms you using the term the term it
warms your art in a situation like this
might be weird but no it's good it's
really good that there's someone out
there that cares with that [__]
system so no it's not it's absolutely
not weird to say it warms your heart
yeah that that lady cares that much
right it's just the whole construct of
of this it warms my heart this little
boy dies and she no it's I understand
but no it's normal that yeah I totally
understand what you're saying yeah and
you're right
so that's it for today's video but uh
say it tough man yeah
see it tough man
remember so many memories
uh
unfortunately it's gonna happen again
and it takes time whenever we talk about
law stuff and stuff like that and things
that need to change in a system it takes
so much time and so many people have to
be aware and this and that whatever so
God speak to that lady
and encourage because it's going to take
a whole lot
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below